Americans collectively owe about one and
a half trillion dollars in student loans
more than twice the total a decade ago
the burden weighs on millions of adults
impacting life choices and often
stunting financial growth one senator
has an idea to help borrow from 401k
retirement plans correspondent Mark
Meredith looks at the proposal and the
potential issues this is a big burden
Kentucky Republican Senator Rand Paul
says too many Americans are struggling
to pay down college debt which is why
he's introduced the helper Act a bill to
let people withdraw up to five thousand
two hundred and fifty dollars annually
from their retirement accounts tax and
penalty free to reduce college loans we
think it would dramatically transform
the way a college is paid for our
country
Paul says with more companies matching
401k contributions even Americans on
smaller incomes are saving money
he says letting people reduce debt now
creates opportunities to save more in
the future
this still encourages saving so it
doesn't work unless you will put aside
savings critics say the idea only helps
a certain class it would be a win for
people who have a lot of money and can
take an extra tax break by investing in
their 401 K first and then taking it out
tax-free but those are the people who
don't actually struggle with student
debt and financial experts warn
retirement account withdraws do come
with long term costs we continue to send
a message that it's best if you can
leave that money untapped and invested
and and let it hopefully benefit from
some growth the senator is also
proposing to let parents withdraw
retirement money tax-free meaning a
student with two parents support could
pay off up to fifteen thousand seven
hundred and fifty dollars worth of loans
tax-free a year Senator Paul tells Fox
News that he has reached out to some
Senate Democrats to build support for
the bill I think there's a big audience
for this and he hopes more students will
speak up to pressure lawmakers to create
more ways to reduce the burden of
college debt Senator Paul says he's
considering expanding his proposal to
offer tax-free benefits to grandparents
of borrowers as well Mike Mark Meredith
thanks very much